Lindsey Vonn is living it up in Monte  Carlo  while her ex Tiger Woods deals with  being arrested for suspicion of driving  under the influence  [Music]  Lindsay seems to be having a better  Memorial Day weekend than her eggs she  posted a series of pigs from her  romantic getaway in France with her  boyfriend Keenan Smith from playing  water sports to rocking a racy red thong  bikini as she looked out at the gorgeous  ocean views from a yacht the  professional skier captioned the pic  keeping my eyes on the horizon the  future is bright  meanwhile 41 year-old Tiger spent time  behind bars in Jupiter Florida on Monday  the golf pro claims no alcohol was  involved telling CBS News in part quote  what happened was an unexpected reaction  to prescribe medications I didn't  realize the mix of medications had  affected me so strongly  according to court docket aim by ET  Tiger was released without bond  [Music]  you